here are the nominees for achievement in
sound mixing
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo David
Parker Michael semanek friend kleiss and
Boo Pearson Hugo Tom Fleischmann and
John Midgley Moneyball Deb Adair
ronbo car David Jia Marco and Ed Novick
Transformers Dark of the Moon
Greg P Russell Gary summers Jeffrey J
kaboosh and Peter J Devlin warhorse Gary
Rydstrom Andy Nelson Tom Johnson and
Stuart Wilson and the Oscar goes to
Hugo Tom placement of John Mitchell
wow this is this is an incredible honor
thanks to the Academy
thanks to Graham King and Tim Headley
headington for producing Hugo many
thanks to my fellow nominees who inspire
me and you do inspire me for years Marty
and Thelma what a joy the privilege has
been to work with you and my wife
Priscilla from her unending love and
support everyone back in New York it
soundtrack and c5 thank you to Dede
Allen and dick for a sec you couldn't be
here tonight but I know you're both
smiling this is such an honor thank you
so much thank you to my crew Mike and
Charlotte thank you and thank you so
much to Martin Scorsese thank you
you